well I think the it's time to party now
typically be serious about what it is we
need to do to be able to stand up for
all of the people who really need a
Labour government and that means both
being strong about our values and also
being determinate enough and strong
enough to deliver them to get a Labour
government elected we can't do that if
we just lurch our narrow party to the
left actually we can't do that if we
simply move a narrow party to the right
either we have got to be strong enough
to be able to reach out you're in danger
though of the party tearing itself apart
I think the party has got to come
together now because in the end look we
think about you know think about
five-year-olds now who've already grown
up under a Conservative government
seeing the shore starts and the
children's centres cut back we're really
going to say to them we want them to
spend their entire childhood under a
Conservative government the way in which
young people's opportunities are being
so hard-hit if we want to deliver for
those children we've got to be strong
enough to get a Labour government
elected we won't do that by just being a
party of protests yeah but the party is
in danger of tearing itself apart as I
said this latest poll is not comfortable
reading apart from perhaps war Jeremy
Corbyn you are in third place is there
an argument for you dropping out so that
one of the other candidates could give
him a run for his money well I think in
the end that all the other candidates I
think are still being too narrow I think
I'm really keen for us to be reaching
out to not just across the party which
we've got to be able to hold together
but also to be able to reach out across
the country that is the only way in the
end we can deliver a Labour government
that can stand up for working people
across the country and build the
stronger economy and the fairer less
divided Britain I think that is what
we've got to do you know this is sort of
you can't just be angry about the world
with a Labour Party we've actually got
to change the world and that means being
able to be able to be true to both our
values and deliver them in practice
because I think what's happening at the
moment is there's a bit of a false
choice going on people thinking you've
either got to stand up for labour values
but beyond electable or alternatively
ditch labour values swallow what the
Tories are saying in order to get back
into government that's a false choice
neither of those approaches will work
for labour we've got to be able to
stand up for our values and be
determined enough to put them into
practice do we need for a choice of four
candidates for that though if you don't
want to step aside perhaps one of your
colleagues should well in the end that's
for them to decide that will be in the
end as well for party members to decide
when they cast their votes but I think
look this is about being really serious
about the task ahead of us because it is
a really tough task ahead of us to be
able to stand up for labour values but
also make sure that we can deliver them
for people you've got a woman in my
constituency who's got huge arrears on
the bedroom tax we're letting her down
if we don't get the labour government
elected so that we can abolish the
bedroom tax the young people who are not
getting those fantastic jobs of the
future that we want them to have we're
letting them down if we're not strong
enough to get a Labour government
elected to stand up for them and make
sure they get those fantastic chances
for the future chatot one of your former
cabinet buddies Miss Beckett's just a
short time ago she as you know she was
one of the people that nominated Jeremy
Corbyn when he was scrabbling around for
people to nominate him she says that on
reflection she regrets that should she
well look I think that's for her to
decide and we know we're having this
debate right across the party but I
think we must not just simply lurch our
party to the left that will not be the
answer we can't go back to the 1980s I
remember growing up in the 1980s we did
a lot of shouting and a lot of
protesting from the sidelines went on a
lot of marches banged a lot of drums
actually we didn't change anything and
we can't do that again we have to be
able to change Britain I I was already
working on Sky News in the 1980s I have
to say and I remember mr. Blair coming
up through the ranks he was certainly a
firm favourite for the party at that
time how much does his intervention help
or hinder today well I think the end
week we can't go back to the 1980s but
we also can't rerun the 1997 election
look that was a great successful
campaign for us but the world's moved on
now we obviously lost votes to the SNP
and to you kit as well as to the Tories
we have to reach out and rebuild in all
directions and of course tires are
changed the economy's moved on
technology's moved on there's different
challenges for the future so we
we can't do a rerun of past elections
and past platforms whether that's 1997
or 2015 none of that will work we've got
to have an optimistic vision for 2020
and beyond how we deliver the high-tech
jobs of the future
but also support the childcare
revolution so that all families can be
part of it but I think end child poverty
in our lifetime that is what the labor
should be campaigning to do in other
words Blair should button it now I think
look everybody we're this is a big
debate about the future of our party
everybody's going to be part of that but
of course there's not going to be a
simple answer from the past that we can
follow actually this has got to be about
Labour's future that is what I want to
do I'm not doing this in order to be
something I'm doing this because I want
us to do something I heard you in the
hustings with Andrew Neil I know you've
got another one too nice I heard you it
was recorded but it was a played out on
Sunday and I also heard Andy Burnham
saying that he wouldn't on balance have
jeremy corbyn as his Shadow Chancellor
his people said subsequently he was just
joking not sure about that would you
have him as part of your Shadow Cabinet
I'm avoiding having any discussions
about a Shadow Cabinet when it presumes
that the an election that hasn't
happened in there in the Labor Party but
look you know Jamie's politics are very
different to mine so I think that would
be it would be a rather tough ask I'm
afraid what does that mean they're very
different to yours and it would be a
tough ask you wouldn't have him in your
cabin Shadow Cabinet is what you say for
example I think that I think the debt
and the deficit have to come down I
don't think you can just wish them away
you've got to have a responsible
approach I don't think by the way you do
that the way the Tories are doing it and
George Osborne's plan now for a 40
percent cut to our public services that
is ideological the Tories today that
would you potentially serve in jeremy
corbyn's Shadow Cabinet if he won again
I think I'm not pre-empting a vote that
hasn't happened I think it would I think
it unlikely we will reach that situation
but I'm not going to get drawn into
because you'll then ask me a whole
series of other questions about
different candidates and so on and I
think look this is a this is for the
Labour Party now to decide about who the
leader should be rather than getting
into speculation that actually came
almost out of time and you've tiptoed
through the raindrops beautifully as you
always do I suppose my final question
would
this process has taken too long hasn't
it well it's you know the timetable was
decided by the party there's some people
saying it's too short some people saying
it's too long we've got to get on with
it but we do have to face there is a
fairly serious choice for the Labour
Party now and I think it's really
important to the Labour Party doesn't
just choose someone who makes us feel
good about the party or about ourselves
it's actually about choosing somebody
who can be strong enough to stand up to
the Tories now and say our an
alternative vision strong enough to be
an alternative labour Prime Minister
from the start that's what I want to do
it must be laughing up his sleeve at all
this going on my husband dad do you mean
indeed sir he's where he's been as
you've been at the cricket on Sunday so
he's been there yet having a nice
relaxing time and doing other kinds of
interviews I forgot there were two Ed's
in your life I must remember that for
next time it's good to talk to you as
always